hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
the podcast that gives and gives and
gives and never takes
I said that without thinking about it
and I immediately regret it
uh how are you what would we take I
don't know I just sometimes we get going
and I don't give it any thought we take
an hour from their lives they can't get
back you're right yeah
um nice to see you both Matt Gourley
Sona mosesian yes yes um yes yes correct
that is my name I am not this is a skin
this is not a border crossing
yes yes and it's subcommittee hearing
yes yes that is correct that's my name
the distinguished gentlewoman from
Altadena
I'd like to mention something that's on
my mind uh which is that
uh recently
um we started this Team Coco channel on
Sirius Radio
and
as you guys know I was not a regular
listener to our podcast right and I'm
I'm not someone who seeks out my work
and wants to enjoy it watch it that's
just not something that I do but what's
interesting is that this serious Channel
started and they play
podcasts that you know the podcast we've
done they play a lot of different
content from over the years and I don't
know what the psychological difference
is but because it's on the radio and
it's just playing
when I get in my car now
I'll turn it on and so I drove to work
today I was in my car listening to
myself
and you guys
um and I was laughing
and I realized this is the most
masperatory thing I've done yeah since I
last masturbated were you masturbating
at the time well I want to try that okay
because that would be I'm I'm sure an
incredible High weren't you worried
about someone driving up and then seeing
Conan O'Brien listening to Conan O'Brien
you know what I do when I I if I pull up
to a light and someone pulls up next to
me and they're in a convertible I lower
my window and I laugh hysterically and I
say it's me I'm on the radio and I'm
killing it I'm as funny as I think I am
yeah confirmed no I just thought I'm
sure that this is I don't intend to do
this a lot but it is funny
first of all I've forgotten a lot of
things yeah and so we've done so much
over a number of years hasn't been that
long but we've done a lot of stuff so
I'm listening to it with fresh ears what
were you listening to which episode I
was listening to us with JB Smoove do
you like it do you like this podcast
yeah okay I do I think there are
improvements that could be made what
improvements well sauna what do you
think you bring to the table you know
what I mean
no I really do I I don't even know I
enjoy it uh and it was just funny
because I thought oh this is a new level
this is a new low as I why do you think
it's a low it's okay because I shouldn't
be listening to myself there's nothing
wrong with this being like hey you know
what good job cones saying that to
yourself that's not what I do I don't
say oh good job cones I say you're
killing it at least you admitted
at least you admit it I think there are
some people that wouldn't admit that
they listen to themselves I high-fived
myself that's when you're mad that means
both him no okay well first of all I use
one of those trucker devices what what
yeah they plug into the yeah you can buy
them Oh you mean like a Fleshlight let's
just say that you
I I was a trucker for a while whoa oh my
God in between games all the jobs that
you could pretend you've ever done hey
guess what trucker is the most
far-fetched you know that it is I did go
to trucking school and I took a class uh
and I drove a big rig and you can watch
it it was a late night remote okay it
isn't for jokes and yucks no but I
actually did have to learn how to drive
what we call in the business the big rig
I think there's so many truckers that
just are so angry right now listen I the
the course was just a couple of hours
and I took it maybe 25 years ago but I
think I'm every
bit as good a truck or as any trucker
out there right now
hold it there's a device
that can plug in it's like a if one
wants to pleasure oneself while driving
um it's no hands uh so it is a
fleshlight yeah does it plug into the
cigarette lighter why do you need to
plug it in well I prefer there's one now
that's solar powered oh you just you
just you attach a little uh thing to the
to the roof of your car the sunroof
because I'd like to go Eco and be green
sure but what's it is it doing
excuse me what do that again why are you
do that
come see the human flashlight live on
stage
I mean first of all what is it dude why
are you plugging it in I mean can't you
just also why do you even need it to
also it's not just truckers I'm thinking
that do this you must understand what
I'm talking about here I think you're on
a long trip and you're driving your
truck oh am I hauling cab over Pete and
a Kenworth 18-wheeler with 18 gears
there you go there you go yeah right and
then you're far away uh you're lonely
yeah uh and then you gotta take care of
business but you don't want to take your
hands off the wheel 10 10 on the side
I'm hiding pickles in the shade I got a
bear in the air oh yeah I said let's
that Tucker roll 10-4 because
going through the night no you're
climaxing as you're driving isn't that
dangerous oh but when you're when you're
hauling yep tell them just tell them
what is it full of logs or you got uh uh
a reefer which is refrigerated uh cargo
what yeah and you're you're going when
you're when you're hauling reefer you're
and you're stacked in your Peterbilt and
you're heading down oh man I'm getting
excited dude no and you're you're
heading down the old concrete Highway
yeah uh you um you need sometimes to
blow off some steam and that's when the
old whoop whoop whoop comes in you got
the Bandit running blocker for you he's
bound and down long way to go short time
trying to get there
you got um uh Contraband coolers yeah
got to get over the Arkansas state line
yeah you've got to help Texas you got to
help Sally Field so yeah okay we went
too far oh you guys did a long time ago
I don't know choke and Pew can get a
Diablo Sandwich okay oh my God have you
memorized that this is one of my
favorite have you memorized the movie
one of the great movies of all time oh
that's what Burt Reynolds yes okay Jerry
Reed oh my God Jerry's musician ever
lived yeah you know what I'll agree with
you uh shout out to the late uh Jerry
Reed one of the great Pickers of all
time who wrote um wonderful songs uh for
Elvis Presley among some and it was a
great recording artist in his own right
and uh then uh went on to be the
sidekick in the the Bandit movie he's a
really good actor terrific I never got
to meet him I wish I'd met him I'm
jealous but anyway I'm worried that we
got off topic which is a device that
Pleasures your penis when you plug it in
or there is a uh solar option okay wow
so let's get the word out on that is
there one that you could plug into a
potato like those old little kids clocks
and you could and it powered that way I
don't think so I'm working on it most in
my childhood everything was powered by a
potato
myself and so I
there was just way too many potatoes in
my childhood so no it would uh that's a
boner killer right there
um anyway this took a turn for the worse
yeah but a shout out to the late Jerry
Reed uh and to truckers everywhere uh we
respect what you do and to anyone who
needs to use a device that plugs into a
cigarette lighter to relieve themself on
the road I mean these are all things
that I just want to make sure that we
wrap up and salute them in that order
yes okay okay